This program is vulnerable.
This really simplified program what
it's doing is something similar to what
a password checking program might do.
Think about what the program is doing,
this is our main
function as the program.
It has take some arguments.
It has bunch of local variables.
It has an integer that's value at
the end is going to be should login be
allowed or not allowed.
It has a local variable
of size no more than 12.
Well that's where we're going to read
the password that we're going to ask
the user to type.
And then we have to compare that with
something that we know about
the password of the user.
So the target password here really
is the password we are looking for.
Here is a really poor practice here,
but the target password is hard coded.
Other thing I should mention here
is that password checking programs
actually don't need to keep your
password because then if somebody
gains control of that then
they know your password also.
So these are sort of the local variables
that we declare in this function.
This is where we get to this code.
The code is very simple.
It's saying I'm going to get a string.
Gets is read a string function get
a string that you're going to type.
We're going to read that string into
this local variable pwdstr that we
declared, then we're going to do
a comparison of the string that we just
read into pwdstr against our target
password, which is my password 123.
This string compare actually is,
this variant says at most
12 character long strings and the result
of this comparison, if the two strings
are identical then it returns a 0,
otherwise it returns a non zero value.
So read more about this function
to find out exactly what
it returns in the other cases,
less than zero or greater than zero.
So in this case, allow_login = 1,
after that we going to say if
allow_login = 0, remember that was
the initial value, we had shown that
we don't allow unless there is a match.
Remember the fail safe
defaults we talked about?
So the default here is don't allow.
So that's why we're setting it to zero.
So if the variable is not set to 1 as
a result of a successful comparison
then it's still 0 then in that case we
are going to reject the log in request.
Otherwise the match was successful.
We set it to 1, so in that case,
we're going to allow the log in request.
But the goal here is to understand how
vulnerable our code gets exploited.
So we want to see how
this code gets exploited.
And this simple program that
we have here helps us do that.